today we're going to be working through
these five problems that you can see on
the screen now I know when you have a
look at these problems to begin with it
doesn't seem like that much apart from
plane geometry that binds these
questions together and that's actually
kind of the point of me showing you
these five problems at the same time
it's also the reason why I have given a
sort of mysterious enigmatic not very
descriptive title to this video because
actually one of the things I want you to
do right now and pause the video if you
want to do this yourself is to have a
think about the kind of mathematics that
is actually underneath all of these
problems and knowing what mathematics is
involved in solving a question is
actually I'm going to suggest part of
the mathematics that you're doing like
it it involves mathematical thinking to
work out what kind of mathematical
thinking you need to do to solve a
question and in fact sometimes being
told ahead of time oh this is a question
to do with Calculus oh this is a
question to do with a probability
density function being told that gives
you this clue already that sort of takes
away some of the work that we normally
have to do in the real world when we
encounter a problem and it is not at all
apparent what kind of mathematical
techniques or strategies are involved in
solving the problem so as I mentioned
before if you haven't already
pause the video give these questions a
go see if you can work out what is the
wonderfully simple but actually broadly
applicable bit of mathematics that we're
going to be using over and over again to
solve all of these problems
if you've had a go already then uh
welcome back but for the rest of you if
you're looking at you're like it's just
not clear to me okay let me work you
through we're going to do all five of
these uh in sequence and you'll see that
I mean in some ways once you see what
mathematics is involved you're like oh
the question just kind of falls apart
and becomes very easy and elegant to
solve but before you do that it can be a
bit challenging
so the very first one we're going to
start with is this diagram here and even
though there's no question stated you
might be able to guess that what we're
after here is what is the Shaded area
what is this um this purple shaded area
here and actually there are a couple of
problems in this list that I just want
to acknowledge Katrina AG for supplying
the internet with she has a fantastic
set of these kinds of challenges where
there's some very simple geometry very
few numbers and yet there can be some
surprising and uh really insightful
methods that are
encountered stumbled upon as you try and
solve these questions and you can also
solve them in lots of different ways
which viewers of the channel will
probably know I really love doing so if
you're a mathematics educator or even if
you're just a student of mathematics and
you find problems like this really
fascinating then I encourage you to look
up Katrina you can find her on Twitter
and all of her problems so let's have a
go at this if we want to work out what
this shaded area is then because the two
shapes that comprise this are on the
left hand side there's a semicircle here
and then over here there's a quadrant
this shape all around it is just a
rectangle and got everything else
inscribed in there evidently to work out
these two areas we're going to need to
know something about the radii of the
circles that this semicircle and
quadrant are a part of right now there's
a bunch of different ways to do it I
could for example use this big circle or
this you know the circle that goes
around this quadrant and to find its
radius as R and then do everything from
there right like find out what R is
given this this four measurement that's
the only thing we've got
um but rather than designate this uh
this length here this vertical side as R
I'm actually not going to do that
because as soon as I make this length R
what I'm going to have to deal with is
Ron 2 over here because
um to do with this radius it's going to
be exactly half of that length I
mentioned over there so being that I can
arbitrarily Define what R is that's up
to me I'm going to choose a location or
a value for r that means I don't have to
deal with any fractions because that's a
bit easier for me right so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to define the
midpoint of this vertical length here
and I'm going to say okay well that's
the center of the circle that makes up
this semicircle so therefore I can say
that I'm going to have R here and here
let's call that the radius which
therefore implies going over to the
other side of the rectangle that the
radius of this larger Circle here is
going to be double that right so it's 2R
so you can see how I either have R and
two r or r on 2 and R but the the actual
value of R doesn't matter based on what
we choose this just means I don't have
to deal with fractions
okay now this is nice but you might
notice I've got a problem here which is
that these links here are the R's here
and the two are here they're vertical
and I know very little about the
vertical dimensions of this rectangle
all I've got is this horizontal length
so I have to try and combine these in
some way meaningfully to work out uh you
know what is this value R and therefore
I'll determine the area from there
now there's one last piece of the puzzle
and it's a circle property or a theorem
that applies to circles that you kind of
need to know in order to solve this
which is that if you actually imagine
you can see I've got my semicircle and
I've got my quadrant right
and uh they are uh tangential to each
other you can see they just touch at
least that's the way that it's drawn
okay now what that means is that another
sort of you know corollary of that is
that if you were to draw a tangent right
in the middle here
that would sort of do the job okay
because these circles are tangent to
each other that means they are both
tangent to this line that I've just
drawn this interval right and so what
that means is uh the way the way that I
can um sort of take that that fact away
or apply that fact is that if I draw the
radius from the center of a circle to
any tangent of that Circle so for
example if I draw from this center of
the circle and draw to that radius one
of the properties that you get here is
that this radius here is perpendicular
to the right the uh to the tangent at
the point of contact let me say that
again this radius is perpendicular to
the tangent at the point of contact so
this spot here where the point of
contact is is actually a right angle
okay however I can make the same
argument for the circle on the other
side of the rectangle right what I can
do is from this Center if I draw over to
the same tangent this should also be
right angled right so therefore because
I've got actually I should stay back
with that color there because I've got a
right angle here on this side and also a
right angle here on that side what
you've got here is a straight angle
there's 180 degrees going across this
line here and so therefore this these
two radii here from uh one center of the
circle on this side to the other Center
or from the other Center these are
actually not just two independent
intervals they are actually part of one
line so now what I've created I wonder
if the wheels have been turning for you
and you've seen the bit of mats that's
going to be useful to us here
the relationship that gets us from this
four to these which is horizontal to
these R's and two r's which are vertical
is the fact that the four and at least
this R over here they both actually sit
in this right angled triangle that I've
now created on the bottom side of the
rectangle so if I just go back to this
color you can see I've got a right angle
there because it's a rectangle and what
I've got here is that uh you've got a
shorter side a shorter side and now what
I've established is a hypotenuse that is
made up of this radius and this radius
and uh carrying on that idea I've
defined this radius is R this radius is
2R and this is what's going to allow me
using this is the bit of maps that I was
kind of wondering if you would work out
uh Pythagoras's Theorem is going to
relate all these lengths together and
will enable me to find R and therefore
what the area is in fact as you're going
to see in a second I don't even need to
find our if my question is to find the
area because the area is going to be in
terms of r squared and Pythagoras's
Theorem is going to give us something in
terms of r squared so I don't even need
to evaluate R itself to work out the
area
I'm getting a bit ahead of myself let's
actually write this out in this triangle
here and I'm just going to give it a
name just so that I can actually do some
labeling here in triangle ABC
I can say let's have a look square of
the shorter Side Square of the other
shorter side equals now just watch out
here right I've got an R plus 2R so
combined that's obviously 3r and that is
all squared by Pythagoras Theorem so I'm
not going to labor the point that this
is a right angle triangle because we're
standard right out the gate that this is
a rectangle so I've got that and then I
can say well let's just unpack this a
little bit I've got r squared plus 16
equals 9 r squared if I were to subtract
an r squared from both sides that gives
me uh 8 r squared on that side and now
dividing through by 8 I get this now of
course if you wanted you could say oh
therefore the radius is equal to that
you can um take the square root of both
sides you can disregard the negative
because R is defined as a length it's
the radius but as I mentioned before I
don't even need to do that right because
the real question is to work out the
purple area and the purple area is
comprised of
the semicircle and the quadrant Each of
which have their respective radius so a
semicircle is half of a circle and the
radius that's related there is just R
and then the quadrant it's a quarter of
a circle and the radius for this
quadrant is not R it's 2R so I'm going
to put 2R in the brackets there and then
Square so from here I just need to tidy
up a little bit and then I'm going to
substitute in you can see this r squared
let me just highlight for you right it
appears here it appears it will appear
here once I've done a bit of simplifying
so that's why I don't actually need to
evaluate for R because r squared is
already the thing that I need
so what do we got here uh let's just uh
simplify this out this is just going to
be two
I notice that this quarter is going to
cancel out with this 2 squared which is
4 so in fact this is just going to be
um pi times 2
. so what have I got here this is a
single Pi this is two of them that's
going to give me three pi and there were
no like centimeters or meters or things
like that so being this is an area I
will conclude it with units squared
so there you go I hope you found that
satisfying to have a look through and
again the point was if we go back to the
question before I started doing
constructions over it right nothing in
this diagram told you that Pythagoras
Theorem was involved because at least as
presented there are no right angle
triangles for one of the reasons why
Pythagoras's Theorem comes up over and
over again and it's going to come up
again a few more times in these
questions is because right angle
triangles are so easy to form in so many
different places and once you've got the
right angle triangle you can relate the
sides once you've got a few lengths or
even some angles as well